[Aplausos]
[Música]
y
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el 12 de agosto de 2018 andreas llega a
su casa va a su habitación y ve que su
madre le está registrando la mochila
porque desde hace tiempo sospecha que
tontea con drogas andrea se enfada mucho
arroja a su madre sobre la cama y
empieza a golpearle en la cabeza después
la arrastra por las escaleras la lleva
al jardín y le mete la cabeza en un cubo
con agua hasta que un vecino y el ruido
se acerca y consigue que la suelte
buenas tardes me llamo josé ramón
bernácer soy juez de menores y mi
trabajo consiste en realidad en dar
oportunidades y digo en realidad porque
desde fuera lo que hace un juez de
menores es juzgar a jóvenes entre 14 y
18 años que han cometido una infracción
penal que cometen un delito
yo juzgue a andrea y la condene pero la
condene a una oportunidad y lo hice así
porque así lo dice nuestra ley del menor
y así funciona nuestro sistema de
justicia juvenil yo creo que es un
sistema válido y les voy a intentar
convencer de ello en cualquier caso
serán ustedes al final de mi
intervención los que juzguen si ese
sistema les convenció no por una sola
vez van a ser ustedes los que juzguen al
juez
y la primera pregunta que nos podemos
hacer es si estos jóvenes que delinquen
se merecen una oportunidad o porque se
la deberíamos dar admitamos que ante
hechos como el que les acabo de contar y
otros mucho más graves todos sentimos
rechazo y este rechazo hacia el hecho se
traslada también hacia el autor por eso
no es de extrañar que algunos o incluso
muchos duden si se debe dar una
oportunidad a estos jóvenes
pero miren la realidad no es tan simple
si yo ahora les dijese que andrea viene
sufriendo abusos desde los 7 años o que
hace unos meses la anterior pareja de su
madre intentó quemar la casa en la que
estaba ella y sus hermanos pequeños o
que cuando sucedió esto andrea tenía 15
años y nadie se ocupaba de ella porque
sus padres se habían separado habían
rehecho sus vidas con otras personas ya
nadie le interesaba a una adolescente
conflictiva situaciones todas reales que
hemos tenido en el juzgado de menores
digo que a lo mejor sabiendo eso ese
rechazo no es tan grande y ojo porque en
ningún momento estoy justificando eso
que ha hecho andrea con su madre sino
simplemente diciendo que antes aquellos
que dudaban a lo mejor ahora sabiendo
estas circunstancias sí que le daban una
oportunidad
pero miren es que yo creo que actuar mal
no puede ser un motivo para negar una
oportunidad al contrario las
oportunidades hay que darlas pues cuando
hay actos mal hechos cuando se cometen
errores cuando hay fracasos si todo va
bien no es necesario una oportunidad
pero como todos al fin y al cabo tarde o
temprano nos vamos a equivocar o vamos a
actuar mal todos tarde o temprano vamos
a necesitar una oportunidad y porque
nuestros jóvenes
además si se trata de dar oportunidades
quizás nos estamos haciendo una pregunta
equivocada que es ese porque hay que dar
una oportunidad quizás la pregunta
correcta sea para qué porque el por qué
está bien pues para saber las causas de
algo para comprender mejor el presente
pero el por qué es una pregunta que
siempre nos mantiene en el pasado y si
estamos constantemente preguntándonos
por qué dar una oportunidad de estos
jóvenes siempre nos va a venir a la
cabeza esos hechos más o menos graves
que cometen porque dar una oportunidad
andrea después de haberse portado así
con su madre sin embargo si la pregunta
es para que yo creo que la respuesta es
mucho más sencilla porque en el fondo es
la que nos daríamos a nosotros mismos
para que una oportunidad pues para
mejorar para afrontar mejor el futuro
para evitar cometer los errores del
pasado
para que una oportunidad de estos
jóvenes sencillamente para que no
vuelvan a delinquir para que lleguen a
hacer o vuelvan a ser ciudadanos
plenamente integrados en nuestra
sociedad y además tengan en cuenta que
la oportunidad no supone olvidar eso que
han hecho o hacer un borrón y cuenta
nueva en sus vidas la oportunidad es
mejorar y en esa mejora está aceptar las
consecuencias de sus actos y sobre todo
responsabilizarse de ellos
decimos condenado a una oportunidad una
expresión seguro que le llama la
atención un poco sensacionalista porque
no hablo de dar o de conceder una
oportunidad sino condenar a una
oportunidad porque pues porque las
oportunidades de la justicia de menores
tienen diferencia respecto a las que se
nos pueden presentar en otros ámbitos de
la vida por ejemplo estas oportunidades
son obligatorias obligatorias para el
estado porque al principio les decía la
ley así lo dice y ya está
obligatorias para la sociedad porque yo
creo que una sociedad como la nuestra no
se puede permitir el lujo de dar por
perdidos a chicos con 15 o 16 años y
pensar que como cometen delitos con esta
edad van a ser unos delincuentes durante
toda su vida
y también son obligatorias para estos
jóvenes claro como consecuencia de esos
actos que cometen por haber cometido una
infracción penal se les obliga se les se
impone se les condena a una oportunidad
y luego en ellos estará que las
aprovechan o no como veremos luego
aquí algunos se puede extrañar y decir
vamos a ver si la oportunidad es algo
bueno porque hay que imponerles esa
oportunidad y podrán pensar que estos
chicos están deseando ir al juzgado de
menores porque además de delinquir el
juez les va a dar una oportunidad
saben que ocurre que a veces no es fácil
ver las oportunidades porque hay veces
que vienen detrás de experiencias o de
situaciones muy negativas y seguro que
han oído esa expresión de cuando una
puerta se cierra otra se abre vale esa
puerta que se abre es la oportunidad
pero a veces no la vemos por esa puerta
que se ha cerrado antes
y en la justicia de menores las
oportunidades vienen después de muchas
experiencias negativas desde luego de un
delito de una denuncia de un juicio de
una sentencia de una condena y entonces
dónde está la oportunidad piensen que
han realizado unos estudios
universitarios y tienen su título y
además se encuentran un trabajo pero a
los pocos meses cometen un error se
equivocan en ese trabajo y aparece
alguien y les dice no te preocupes mira
te vamos a dar mejor dicho te vamos a
obligar a una oportunidad y es que vas a
empezar una nueva carrera una carrera
fabulosa una carrera adaptada a ti
totalmente y si apruebas a lo mejor te
contratamos luego y ustedes dicen y qué
oportunidad es esa otra vez a estudiar
no sé si voy a aprobar no sé si voy a
encontrar trabajo
dónde están las oportunidades en la
justicia de menores pues miren las
oportunidades en la justicia de menores
están en que las penas que imponemos los
jueces que además no se llaman penas se
llaman medidas tienen siempre un
contenido educativo el sentido amplio y
además si esto es muy importante están
adaptadas a la situación concreta de
cada menor
porque lo que se trata es de saber qué
circunstancias han influido en el delito
que ha cometido ese menor y trabajar
esas circunstancias y por eso en los
centros de menores
claro que chicos y chicas encerrados por
mucho muchísimo tiempo y que no pueden
salir pero sobre todo lo que hay son
clases de matemáticas de lengua de
inglés talleres de educación
afectivo-sexual de prevención y
tratamiento de consumo de buen uso de
nuevas tecnologías y en otro tipo de
medidas pues se colabora con entidades
de interés social se proporciona
asistencia psicológica terapia familiar
es decir realmente objetivamente se
trata de oportunidades lo que ocurre es
que muchos jóvenes al principio y con
cierta razón lo único que ven es lo que
dice la sentencia dos años de
internamiento tres de libertad vigilada
100 horas de prestaciones
y les decía antes que estas
oportunidades se pueden aprovechar por
estos jóvenes y que hace falta para
aprovecharlas pues yo creo que cuatro
elementos o para ser más precisos 3 1 y
luego verán porque se paró el último el
primero la aceptación y fíjense lo que
tienen que aceptar muchos de estos
jóvenes simple y llanamente es que su
vida es un desastre
créanme si les digo que el menor
problema que tienen muchos de estos
chicos y chicas es ese delito que les
lleva a la justicia de menores
los problemas más graves están detrás
familias muy conflictivas con esos
padres que no quieren no pueden o no
saben ocuparse de ellos problemas de
consumo problemas de salud mental
fracaso escolar y admitir esto a esa
edad yo creo que a cualquier edad pero
imagínense con 14 15 16 años reconocer
esto y aceptar esto es muy duro pero sin
duda es el primer paso para poder
cambiar una aceptación 2 decisión
decisión
decisión de cambiar porque lo que
tenemos que tener muy claro es que ellos
son los dueños de sus vidas y miren
cometer un delito es una decisión sin
duda alguna lo que ocurre es que muchos
de estos jóvenes toman esa decisión
condicionados por las circunstancias en
las que viven yo siempre he dicho que es
muy fácil ser un buen ciudadano cuando
naces en una familia que te quiere que
te apoya cuando tienes posibilidades de
estudiar cuando vives en un entorno que
no es especialmente conflictivo así
cualquiera
lo difícil es ser un buen ciudadano
cuando esas circunstancias son
totalmente las contrarias pero entonces
llega la justicia de menores y lo que
intenta es dar las circunstancias que
tenemos la mayoría a estos jóvenes y que
se vean capaces de estudiar de vivir sin
consumos de controlar sus impulsos de
tener una relación normal con su familia
y cuando tengan estas circunstancias que
decidan lo que quieren hacer o dejar de
hacer porque entonces esa decisión sí
que será totalmente libre y serán
plenamente responsables de ella y por
eso esto que voy a decir es muy
importante para los que trabajamos en
esto y yo creo que para ustedes también
lo será este sistema de justicia juvenil
no fracasa cuando algunos de estos
jóvenes deciden seguir delinquiendo te
duele te da lástima
pero no es un fracaso del sistema es su
decisión personal y de ella deberá
responder el sistema fracasa cuando es
incapaz de dar oportunidades para tomar
esa libre decisión
y les decía una aceptación 2 decisión 3
esfuerzo porque tomar esa decisión es
relativamente fácil es instantáneo lo
difícil ponerlo en práctica estudiar
primero de la eso cuando tienes 17 años
o dejar los consumos cuando lo has
estado haciendo desde los 12 es un
proceso largo lento con altibajos y por
eso ténganlo muy presente las
oportunidades de la justicia de menores
no se regalan sino que hay que
trabajarse las
una aceptación 2 decisión 3 esfuerzo
para cambiar y les hablaba de un cuarto
elemento ese 31 separado porque este
elemento sí que no depende de la
voluntad de los jóvenes como ocurría con
los otros y este elemento es el apoyo el
acompañamiento a esos jóvenes durante
todo este proceso y aquí me van a
permitir que les cuente una anécdota
personal porque yo en otras vidas
judiciales anteriores estuve en otro
tipo de juzgados y era muy feliz en él
con mi trabajo pero bueno pues las
circunstancias de la vida hicieron que
quisiéramos venir a toledo donde estaba
nuestra familia y aquí nos vinimos la
única vacante que había el juzgado de
menores y después de estar un tiempo en
el juzgado de menores me di cuenta de
que esto era otro mundo y no tenía nada
que ver con esos otros juzgados y fue
por esto que les voy a contar un día voy
a un centro de menores a este centro de
menores que aparece ahí de ciudad real a
ver a mi chicos y chicas que es algo que
hacemos todos los jueces de menores
periódicamente vamos allí a
entrevistarnos a solas con los jóvenes
que hemos condenado a estar allí
y un día hablando con un chico de
repente se acuerda de algo se echa mano
al bolsillo saca un papel doblado me lo
da y dice toma las notas efectivamente
lo cojo lo desdobló y en las notas del
segundo trimestre de primero de la eso
el chico tenía 17 años
y me dice he aprobado todo hasta
matemáticas
cuando volvía en el coche de ciudad real
tenía una sensación agridulce porque me
daba mucha alegría que este chico
compartiera conmigo una noticia que para
él era buena y era importante pero me
daba mucha pena que una de las pocas
personas que tenía para compartir esta
noticia y que sabía que la iba a valorar
era el juez que le había condenado a
estar tres años encerrado en ese centro
hay que estar con ellos y acompañarles y
no lo digo en un plan paternalista ni
sobreprotector al fin y al cabo lo que
hay que darles es lo que hay que dar a
todo joven límites coherencia
comprensión felicitarles cuando hacen
las cosas bien regañarles con un poquito
de esperanza cuando las hacen mal lo
triste es que no tienen a nadie en su
entorno próximo que les dé esto y por
eso en los juzgados de menores no solo
hay jueces fiscales abogados
funcionarios policías eso más o menos lo
hay en todos los juzgados lo que hay
sobre todo son educadores trabajadores
sociales psicólogos profesores
comunidades autónomas asociaciones de
todo tipo cada uno en su papel pero
todos fundamentales en este papel de
acompañar a los menores pues yo creo que
con estos elementos apoyo y aceptación
esfuerzo y decisión de cambiar se pueden
aprovechar estas oportunidades yo estoy
seguro que casi están convencidos pero
con esto aún más porque algunos se
preguntarán muy bien pero este sistema
luego funciona este sistema es válido
pues miren definitivamente sí pero
funciona solo porque más del 80% de los
jóvenes que pasan por los juzgados de
menores no vuelven a delinquir jamás más
del 80 por ciento pero no sólo por eso
sobre todo porque la justicia de menores
no es una cuestión de números sino de
personas y la realidad es que nuestros
barrios en nuestras ciudades hay muchas
andreas y muchas familias angustiadas
con la situación de estos jóvenes y en
la medida en que la justicia de menores
da una respuesta a estas situaciones no
castigando sino proponiendo un futuro
pues no cabe duda yo no tengo duda de
que es un sistema válido y termino y
termino para decirles que no piensen que
la justicia de menores es exclusiva de
los jueces ni de los profesionales que
antes les decía la justicia de menores
es de todos y también de ustedes
y ahí están
ahí están abraham rafael que de óscar
lucía y sara y en más o menos tiempo van
a salir del centro
y yo les pregunto
están ustedes dispuestos a apoyar a
acoger a acompañar a estos jóvenes en
sus institutos en sus barrios en sus
trabajos
ustedes también les condenaría a una
oportunidad
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
sí